thank you I'm gonna try really hard not
to wander away from the podium because I
don't this lapel mic apparently doesn't
go to these speakers but just start like
throwing things at me if I start
wandering that way to point things
that's what I like to do I will talk
about coronavirus not in this talk at
the bar maybe but you have to have
gotten your influenza vaccine if you
want to talk to me about it because
that's much much much more important
okay okay and you have to wash your
hands before you come after me so just
those two things
those are just my usual stipulations for
talking to me that's got nothing to do
with the corona virus so so tonight I
want to talk about something that I've
been I've been thinking about for a
while which is you know we all know the
role that our packages play in our
day-to-day lives in terms of data
analysis you know we load dir ggplot
makes our lives a lot easier
you know bless cran there's I mean how
many now ten 16,000 17,000 packages on
cran
it's crazy sometimes I think that there
is this divide because R is a
programming language both for data
analysis and also it's a full-blown
programming language you know you can do
software engineering with it
I sometimes feel that there's this a
little bit of a divide quiet divide
where people are using R in their
day-to-day lives they're using it every
day at their work but they feel like
that that space between writing our code
for their analysis and writing our code
as a package is is quite vast and I have
been thinking a lot lately about how
that should not be the case in large
part because the tools have gotten so
good for our package development that
they're very
very intuitive now and it's much much
easier to pick this stuff up so at the
at the art studio conference this year I
was I was giving a workshop with who was
my supervisor at our studio routine in a
workshop called my organization's first
hour package and this this workshop the
idea behind it was that we were going to
teach people how to make our packages to
use in their in their work so packages
for their inside their company for their
research team that sort of thing
code that they're using all the time
plot themes connecting to their
databases this sort of thing so rather
than thinking about something that I
might ship off the crayon that you know
millions people are gonna download or
whatever no it's just for our local team
so it was there that I started thinking
about really that the tools have gotten
so good for this and the art packet
structure is so useful that this should
really be a part of our everyday toolkit
our packages and there was a talk that
happened there by by someone named Emily
reader who's who's fantastic she had a
series of blog posts by the same name as
her talk which was our markdown driven
development and she's got this great
blog post that's linked in the sides
here about how we can take an R markdown
file and slowly transition it into a
better workflow she's very interested in
workflows and towards the end of this
transition you sort of realized wait a
minute this is actually in our package
and so she she posited that while we had
been you know cramming all of our our
code just into this single document into
an R markdown document it actually works
really really well as in our package and
when I was listening I had read her
materials about this and when I was
listening to her speak she at one point
she said about coding projects that
there is actually a as she put a latent
our package
in your project so it's already there it
just hasn't manifested itself as in our
package and so these two things clicked
for me at once when I heard that and I
thought of this this quote from a poem
in the Zen literature it's from a poem
called the Sandow car that the relative
the identity of relative and absolute it
says if you do not see the way you do
not see it even as you walk on it
in Zen there's this belief that's you
know in Buddhism you're striving for
enlightenment right that's kind of the
end goal of Buddhism so to speak and in
Zen in several other schools there's a
belief that actually already enlightened
you you are already perfect and complete
as you are and you just don't realize it
and so much of the effort of Zen is
coming to realize that that you are
already there and so in my mind these
two ideas linked that's when you're
working on your project you are actually
working on in our package and you just
don't realize it yet so the point of
today's talk is to try and convince you
that your project is already in our
package and that you are already in our
package developer and have the skills to
dive right in this evening after the bar
if you hunt because you already have
been working on the skills that you need
to do this you are already walking the
path of the developer so to speak so the
first thing has anybody ever seen these
images before in the background to the
of my slides here it's got a guy
searching here yeah they're called the
Ox hurting pictures if anybody's
interested you should look them up
they're very interesting so each part of
this is going to talk about something
that you're doing in your project
already and how it directly connects to
to what you might be doing if you were
working on in our package and and in
fact you want so my first point is that
you you're already structuring your
project right so we all have our
different ways of doing this maybe yours
doesn't look like this
but I often often set up data analysis
projects like this where I have a folder
for my data I have a folder for reports
you know this is where I put my our
markdown documents that kind of thing
sometimes I have a figures folder
sometimes I kind of let our markdown
handle those details often I have a
scripts folder that's where I'll put my
functions I'll load my packages that
sort of thing and then you know I love
our studio so I always have everything
is in our studio project so there's
always an our proj file in there for me
so the scripts folder in our package
speak might be what in our package is
the our folder and in this is where your
our functions go so you know when you
load ggplot they're pulling these
functions out of the scripts that are in
this our folder so this is sort of a
natural place to be thinking about you
know you have these scripts that you've
developed to be putting them into a
setting that are knows how to work with
as a package although actually some
people who use this approach they put
functions in the our folder and then
they also have a scripts folder that
this is something that they would you
know be running when they want to
compile there were all of their reports
and stuff or whatever the art package
structure already has a folder for data
so this is this is pretty easy of a
match reports can be a wide variety of
things but there is a convenient type of
object in our packages that I'm sure
most of you have used all right which is
the vignette so most thing yets these
days not all of them of course but most
vignettes these days are just our
markdown files and you can go to the
github zuv of your favorite packages and
and look in this vignettes folder and
you will see in our markdown document
that has the same thing that you you
know when you wanted to learn about that
package that you went and looked up so
this is a very sensible place to
transition to reports our packages also
have a few other items that you don't
normally see in in a project we have
something for documentation although
I'll argue a little bit later that
you're already docking
in your code this just makes it explicit
it just puts it in its proper home I
also try and convince you that you're
already writing tests and you're just
not putting them in the test folder and
running them automatically which is
making your life harder and then usually
you'll see a description file and a
namespace file as well so one of my
favorite packages this is a little bit
small one of my favorite packages is to
use this package does anybody ever use
to use this okay how about dev tools
yeah good good who's made in our package
okay pretty good so use this is a newer
package it's not brand new but it's a
newer package in the dev tools ecosystem
that broke out a lot of the packet a lot
of the functions that dev tools
Hadley wickham's package for developing
our packages into a more focused amount
of functionality and so this has quickly
become one of my favourite packages to
use so it's got this function create
package and then it gives you a lot of
information about what it's doing so if
you're starting scratch you might want
to think about it this way where you'll
use this create package folder and then
one of the things that it's doing is
creating this description file so the
description file at face value is kind
of boring
it's metadata it tells you a little bit
about what's going on in the package
what does it do who developed it this is
just how it comes by default use this
knows who I am so I put my name in there
correctly but outside of that it doesn't
know what my package is supposed to do
or anything like that so this is this is
pretty boring at face value but I
actually think that I have come to think
that this is the most interesting file
in the entire our package structure and
this is actually your golden ticket to
the to the R package ecosystem and one
of the big reasons that I think it's
even worth thinking about that you might
make this transition from project to
cage is because when you create things
as a package you get to tap into the
ecosystem out there that helps you helps
you make the code that is robust it
works you can run tests you get free
access to things like package down which
creates websites for packages and that
sort of thing and a whole host of other
automated tools that make your life
easier so having a description file is
what gets you there so use this also has
this this function create project and it
has a function called use description so
create project is if you're in our
studio and you kind of go through the
pulldown menu and go new our studio
project I'm assuming everybody is using
our studio projects which isn't
necessarily a fair assumption you should
really think about it if you're not yes
oh yes yes well that's right and I
actually said our studio projects but
it's even more fairs not everybody uses
our studio including some people at our
studio don't use the IDE just true I
don't know so but projects are nice
because they sought they hope they saw
the whole host of workflow problems for
you
so I really recommend using our studio
projects if you're not but assuming that
you are it's also got this function
create project and this function use
description so use description is really
cool because if you could if you go to a
project that is already active that you
already have going and you use use
description they'll start with use
underscore something by the way if you
use use description it will create this
description file for you and put
into your project and so when I do that
it knows now that this is it thinks that
this is a package because this is the
most basic file that I need to tap into
the infrastructure that our studio and
other places provide you for working
with packages so description files are
really great now I'll give you a few
examples as we go along why that's the
case so you already structure your
package your project has a package even
if you don't realize it you already
write our code of course otherwise you'd
be at like the sass meetup or or
something like that but you're not
you're here so you're already right you
know sass has a has a really big grasp
on epidemiologists so so I have to be
very polite about sass in general
because I'll hurt friendships okay so
you know so you're already you're
already writing our code right you know
you've got code that maybe looks like
this I'm grouping iris by species and
then I'm trying to get the mean supple
length I just learned that was
pronounced supple by the way in my head
I always pronounced it sepal which
apparently is not correct that's what I
get for learning about flowers through
our right so we have code and we run it
interactively a council maybe we use the
source function to run a bunch of code
at once so a lot of things that I'm
going to suggest from here on out I'm
going to take something that you're
doing already in a project and I'm I'm
going to show you what kind of shift
that you need to make to think about it
in terms of in our package so the first
shift that you need to think about when
you're doing these sorts of things is
that it needs to be as I said in a file
called R right that's where our packages
find functions that it exports so use
this has a little helper function it's
called use R it's a very simple function
it just creates a file for you and it
opens it up puts it in the right place
and opens it up for you alright so I
created a new our file called summarize
data and it told me all right I'm gonna
open this up and I want you
modify summarize dated are the next
shift that you have to think and you may
you may already think in these terms
which is great is writing your code as
functions so our packages provide you
functions right and so if you're going
to be thinking about changing your
project to a package you need to be
thinking about refractory code that
looks like this where you just have line
line line that's running in the council
or with source into something like this
that's wrapped in a function okay and
and the nice thing about analysis
projects as functions is often you can
just do a little a little wrapper around
it so you don't have to be like writing
Hadley level api's complex stuff like
this you know he's so interested in like
the philosophy of the API is that he
designs like you don't have to think
about that kind of stuff at all like you
can just wrap it in the function
function and you'll be good right so
that's a that's the first shift that you
need to think about the second shift is
that you won't be running that function
code in the council either so you may
have a project that has a function in it
and then you run it in the council and
then that functions available to you in
our package what you need to do is use
the dev tools package dev tools has a
couple of functions for this actually
one that's really neat is load all and
it's loading this package for me and
then it gives me access to this function
that I just created in summarize data
that are so now rather than sourcing it
or rather than running in the council I
used load all there's also a keyboard
shortcut in our studio command shift l
if you're on a Mac control if you're on
Windows and then there's also a function
called build which actually this sort of
like it's it sort of simulates building
in our package and loading everything
into your into your local environment
there's also a function called build
that will actually build everything and
it will the our package will be
installed on your machine message okay
so um this is one that maybe you don't
think about but you already declare your
dependencies which is a really really
important thing in our packages so you
how you share code or somebody sends you
code usually it's somebody sending you
code and you try and run it and it just
sort of doesn't work and they're like
well it works on my machine right but
more or less when you install something
from cran or even if you even saw
something from github that's an R
package when you load that our package
the functions in it just sort of work
right every once in a while you bump
into an issue where I don't know they
didn't declare things right or your
system is really wonky and and something
went wrong but by and large when you
download a package it just works right
you don't have to think about do I have
all of these other packages to help me
do that so whether you realize it or not
you're already doing this to some degree
by loading packages in the first place
so if if I've got a script here that's
running a function called plot iris I
need deep liar for this because this is
calling some deep layer code and that's
when you do do plot - so up at the top
here I've got library deep liar and
library ggplot2 and these are my
dependencies if you don't have these on
your computer this function is not gonna
work all right you need to do this and
recently our studio added something
that's pretty nice where it will
actually looked at the script you have
open and it will figure out if you have
those packages installed and will offer
to install it for you which is like a
mind-blowing feature it's so great so
that's made my life a lot less painful
getting getting code that way sometimes
even my own old code where I'm like I
just have not reinstalled a package or
whatever and I'm like what idiot
designed this and it's me so the shift
that you need to make when thinking
about using packages that are from
somewhere else when you're creating a
package is that you have to declare them
formally as dependencies so use this has
a function called use package it's very
simple use package quote unquote deep
liar so here's the thing about about
these use this function so we've got
back here use our and we've got use
package here when I was a when I was
sort of like informally declaring my
dependencies up here by using library
this was in my code
right this is what I sent to my
colleague or whatever and it was right
there
this used this code is actually kind of
ephemeral it it disappears when it's
gone you just type it into your console
it gives you some information about it
but you're not actually saving it
anywhere so sometimes what I see is is
when people first learn use package
they'll actually put this in their our
folder in their our script use package
dpi or something like that but you
actually don't need to do that you just
need to run it once because what it's
doing is it's adding it to that
description file
so as I'm adding deep liar and ggplot to
the imports section okay so the third
ship that you have to make when you're
using packages from somewhere else is
unfortunately you you kind of you don't
get anymore free lunch with not having
to write the name of the package before
the function when you do library package
name you don't have to write group by or
summarize or did you plot or any of
those things but since I'm not actually
attaching the package when I'm when I'm
using it in this package environment I
need to type out the name in full so
group bys real name is deep liar colon
colon group I it just has it just has a
short name that it goes by it which is a
group I that if you're familiar with it
you can load deep liar you can call it
that name and it's fine with that this
is a slightly more formal setting and so
you have to call it by its full name to
be respectful also to find it because I
won't know where to find it if it's not
there so you have to use deep liar colon
colon group by function or package name
colon colon function name so if you
crack open in our package and you look
at the code almost always it will look
like this where it will have a mix of
internal functions base are functions
that don't have the colon colon operator
there and then functions from other
packages that it's using this way and
there's a few tricks that you can use
not to do this but by and large this is
this is the best product the best
practice for it so what happens to that
description file
is that when I use use package it adds
imports ggplot2 and deep liar down here
right
so in some sense I'm just you know I'm
moving this over if somebody wants to
look at my description file and find out
what packages they need to use my
package they can look at this
luckily the our package system takes
care of this kind of stuff for us which
is amazing you know when you when you
install something fresh in your computer
you install ggplot2 fresh on your
computer it installs everything else
that you need right you just have to
type the one line install ggplot to
install the packages did you poo and
then it gives you all this other stuff
that any that it's going to be
installing in the meantime and that's
because it's looking at the description
file and it's figuring out what does it
need to actually run this package so
that's fine if you have a package it's
on crayon but you know you're probably
not going to take your analysis projects
and ship it off to cran because you know
first of all they probably don't want it
they're busy so don't do that and in
second all you'll probably don't want to
do that either
but you may be putting it on github or
locally what you can do is devtool says
this function called install underscore
depths and install depths we'll look at
a pack look at a project they will look
for a description file and it will
install anything that you need to make
this project run which is incredibly
incredibly convenient right if you can
ship your project off to your colleague
who's you know new to art doesn't know
what to do and you say well just run
this line of code and then you'll have
every package that you need to run this
because you can also stipulate here and
through use this other details about
they are packages that you need version
numbers maybe the package lives on
github or gitlab or somewhere else you
can tell dev tools and are where to find
those things and it will install it for
whoever wants to install these things so
this is really convenient sometimes even
on my own projects I'll run this because
I'm very frequently kind of starting
from scratch on things
so these two thing the first two things
writing code and and declaring your
dependency is I probably it probably
didn't take you very long to be like
yeah yeah of course how else would you
run our code this one might take a
little bit of convincing which is that
you already test your code all right so
who's used the test test that package
yeah any other there's a few other
testing Suites in our anybody use
anything else it's like a tiny test
Vickie way has one like his own version
that's just like a kind of minimal
version of the testing suite so test
that is is having these package for
writing writing unit tests in are which
is meant to kind of kick the tires of
your our code to make sure that it
functions well so when I first started
developing our packages this was the
thing that I was like oh god I don't
understand this at all like I don't know
what kind of tests I'm supposed to be
writing I this seems like very like
heady software engineering stuff I don't
I don't really know what I'm supposed to
be doing and so I always put it off
until like the absolute last minute
which just made it worse because you
know spending like two days writing
tests is not a good way to spend two
days the thing is is that you are
actually writing tests all the time for
your code it's just that you're not
doing it formally so here I've got this
function clean data and I'm just trying
it out an IRS here and like okay
something went wrong and I usually make
that face when I'm doing it and then
this kind of seems like it works except
I gave it is and it actually gave me
empty cars back which is not what it's
supposed to be doing all right and so
usually what I would do is I would
fiddle at the council right like I would
kind of iterate between like I go back
to my code I took a few things reload my
function and then I go and I fill around
at the council again this is a test
right so hadley in in his our package of
books says something effective you're
always testing your code you're just not
writing it down right so this is a
formal mechanism for doing this the
problem with this is I might fix this
right this is usually what happens I
figure it out oh yeah I got it it's
great
first of all it will usually break later
because I did something and I didn't
save it or whatever so it breaks again
or I bump into something else
much later down the line and I start
fiddling with that of a console I'm
writing kind of easy Matt these sort of
informal informal fake tests and I fix
that but but I don't realize that I in
the process I broke this bug because I
never wrote this test down I don't know
that right so use this comes with a
whole suite of tools to help you with
this the simplest one is used test which
will I call this clean data it will add
test that to your package it will it
will open the file for you and do a
bunch of other stuff that you need it to
do to run these tests and then dev tools
has this function called test and let
this roll around a second here all right
so it's opening this stuff up and then
dev tools will run a test of this and
give me a report of what's going on so
once I fix that test and I figure out
what's wrong I can encode what I was
secretly doing which was I was running
my function and I had an expectation of
what that function should give me right
and that's the language of test side is
that you can write formal expectations
of what your code should give you and
this is extremely extremely useful in
data analysis projects because data
changes data changes the packages that
you're using change all sorts of things
can go wrong right you accidentally
didn't save a part of a script or you
changed one part and didn't change
another something goes wrong and you
don't realize that your whole report is
broken now right so testing is still
important in data analysis which is why
you're already doing it at the council
okay so this is not just an excuse for
me to get a drink of water
I wanted to take a moment here I have I
have I bore to say on this subject but I
wanted to take a moment here because I
think these ideas here give you the most
bang for your buck in thinking about
project as package so the first big idea
is to use a description file right this
is your golden ticket to the R package
equals to the ecosystem you can you can
start using the useless functions the
dev tool functions and loads of other
neat tricks for making your package
better and it can also help you formally
declare the dependencies that you have
in your project so that people can more
easily run them by installing them
quickly
the second big idea here is to write
code as functions and and this is not
new there's lots of lots of paradigms
that that that suggest that you should
be doing this in your analysis code does
anybody use Drake the Drake package Oh
need to get a Drake talk in here Drake
is awesome I have a link to it at the
end and and that's a big idea it's a
workflow package it's very very nice
and it's centered around the idea that
you should be writing your analysis code
as functions it also does a remarkably
good job caching your code so that you
have to keep rerunning things that you
don't need your own so I highly
recommend looking into it and it
connects with this idea of a packages
project as a package really well and
then the other big idea is that these
things that you're doing at the council
you should write them down as formal
tasks right you you you know how your
function should be acting you have
expectations about how it should be
returning things to you write them down
and automate them it's a little bit of
effort in the moment but it makes your
life a lot easier in the long term
because you can you can track them more
easily and you're already doing it at
the council anyway so you might as well
put it into a formal system okay so this
is a this is a basic our package and
this is a quote that I really like from
from Suzuki Roshi who is who is a
Japanese Zen teacher who came to the
United States and found
many places in the San Francisco area
the area and this is one of my favorites
each of you is perfect the way you are
and you could use a little improvement
and this has actually already been
adapted to our speak by have we how each
package is perfect the way it is right
and it could use a little improvement
right so these ideas here are sort of
like the most basic things that you can
do to explore this idea of having a
project as packaged or even creating a
package you know creating a legitimate
our package that is that is meant to
operate as they normally do for instance
if you want a personal package or if you
want to develop something for your team
or if you want to submit something to
cramp right these tools I mean I only
had three or four lines of code from
from use this and dev tools use code
this is these tools have gotten
extremely easy to take on and they're
very communicative they tell you exactly
what you need to be doing so you don't
get lost and it puts everything it
handles a lot of that tedious detail
about setting up our packages first so
that you can access the power of the our
package and second so you can focus on
your main task of writing code so the
point here is is that don't worry too
much if you feel like okay but this is
not like this is no ggplot2 right like
this is just some some package that I
have because I kept I kept writing the
same plot all the time and I wanted a
function for it the best code is code
that works all right so you don't have
to be you don't have to be a Hadley
level just yes although you already are
you just don't know it all right so a
few quick points about about the rest of
this because I just want to point out my
point out the fact that a lot of the
things you're familiar with with our
packages extend very neatly to
connecting it to an analysis project and
the first is documenting your code right
this is maybe maybe you don't do this
we're told that we should do this right
away
right you should comment your code you
should write function names that are
like it tells you what it does you know
I've gotten a little bit better
at this over the years and I'm still you
know when I'm writing code in this
format where I'm running it in a script
er at the council god better if I know
someone else is gonna be reading it and
there's a little bit of peer pressure
but this is fundamentally documenting
your code right both giving it comments
and giving descriptive names right
giving your variables descriptive names
giving your functions descriptive names
this is documenting code and lo and
behold our packages have a system that
you're already familiar with because
you've already looked at help pages for
functions in packages that you've
downloaded from crayon that formally
document and this uses a rocks gem so
I'm using rocks in user oxygen MD which
lets me write oxygen using a markdown
format which is nice and my code ends up
looking a little bit something like this
instead where I still have comments here
but I have these apostrophes after my
comments and then I have these things
with the @ symbol in front of it that
are called oxygen tags and I'm not gonna
go into the nitty-gritty about you know
what these things do but it it lets you
write your comments in such a way that
will map automatically to the help pages
that functions that you normally see
produce and so when I run documents
which is a dev tools function it will do
a few things in the package that it
needs to do and will also write this
help help page for me so now if I do a
question mark plot IRS a help page for
this has been produced in just just a
few lines so this I know you do because
this is like 8090 percent of the job
hey if only we knew how much time we'd
be spending cleaning data so you already
clean your data right and you've already
used data in the context of our packages
you know I just I've had all these
examples from iris from empty cars
ggplot2 has mpg one of them has some
Star Wars data I think it's I don't know
if it's deep doo-doo plotter deep liar
the point being that our packages have a
formal system for exporting data and
this is really nice when you have a sort
of a steady state data you know data is
often changing and so this won't work
for every situation but if you have you
just need to clean data once and then
have access to it to be able to run a
bunch of reports out of that sort of
thing
this is a really great system for it
use this provides a way of actually
putting your data cleaning script
somewhere in your our package called use
data raw right so creates this space for
me and it will actually open up a file
that I can put my script that I used to
clean my data in so my script looks like
this I like this function a lot clean
names from janitor makes names way
better I'm also taking away some factors
I'm turning things into a table and then
use this also has a function called use
data and this is what actually exports
the data right so iris two is is a data
set that I want to work with because I
love flowers and so I want to be
generating lots and lots of reports
about them and so now when I load my
package IRS two is going to be
immediately available in this format
right so this is also useful for things
you know it may not be useful if for
instance you have to connect to a
database to get your data something
that's changing every day or every hour
or every minute but it may be useful for
storing for instance data dictionaries
for your work testing data for like
quickly testing functions without having
to connect your your database and that
kind of thing and quite a bit more so
you definitely already write reports in
some capacity it's just a matter of if
you're if you're using my favorite tools
for it I hate so my favorite tool for it
is of course our markdown and as I
mentioned our packages already have an
excellent system for producing our
markdown reports which are vignettes so
this is the most basic way this doesn't
work for everything but if you have a
report that pretty much stays steady
that you just need to re-render every
once in a while vignettes are really
nice because there's already a formal
way of putting them into the package and
then building them over and over
and then you know you can easily call
the functions that you wrote in your pen
your your our folder inside of that bin
yet you'll also see people putting it
into a folder called inst in stands for
installed files and this is sort of a
this is like your the hidden space in
the trunk of your car we can kind of
sneak whatever the heck you want and you
are a package the top level of the our
package is kind of strict right you have
certain things that you're supposed to
put in there and certain things that
you're not supposed to put in there inst
you can put it pretty much put whatever
you want in and it will build it and it
will install those files and in fact
that's what it stands for is installed
files so sometimes what you'll see
people do is that they'll put reports
into a folder in here so this I'm
creating directory with the FS package
called reports and when I build my
package that report is available inside
of the package so if somebody else
installs it from github or I sharing the
installation file to someone that
reports available to them and then
finally even though I said that the top
level of our packages can be pretty
strict I can create something at the top
level and then use a function called use
build ignore because our packages have a
mechanism of letting you say okay just
when you're building your package don't
worry about this folder don't worry
about this function all right this is uh
this is a bunch of analysis stuff you
don't need to know it when you're
actually building a package but you
wouldn't maybe have it in a repository
and so earlier when I mentioned that
some people will have an R folder and a
scripts folder they do something like
this with the scripts folder because the
scripts folder is not a valid our
package folder at the top level whereas
R is so you need to build ignore it but
you have a lot of options here right so
it kind of depends on the needs of your
ports very often you know I'm scientist
so very often I have to just have to
write one paper and then like that's it
I might have to make some changes to it
but it's not a it's not a report that's
changing for me every day you know so so
the vignette structure makes a lot of
sense for me in a lot of cases but if
you need more flexibility really it's
it's it's your choice how you go about
that
so finally you already share your code
and it's terrible right I hate getting
our code from other people because I get
a script and it just doesn't run it
never runs I don't I don't know if I've
ever gone it's an R code from somebody
else that ran right away something about
my system is different than your system
and our packages are meant to solve that
problem that's the biggest problem that
they saw they are the fundamental unit
of shareable R code right so they're
meant to work very easily on somebody
else's machine so you know you can put
this on get you know happily says that
regardless we're guarding this issue of
like bringing the pain on yourself as
the developer is that the whole point of
this is to make things easier as easy as
possible on your user which usually
means making things harder on yourself
so I do agree that we actually
submitting to cran is a commitment and I
think sometimes people don't think about
that they just want to get it up there
and they're not thinking long-term about
like am I actually gonna be able to
maintain this package do I have a plan
if I can't you know what happens if it
breaks next week and might and I need to
fix it right away but I also think that
the you know the infrastructure is such
that with with github and other tools
for sharing packages that the vast
minority of packages said you can be
thinking about going on cran because I
think that this should be an everyday
tool I think that that should be you
have a package you want to distribute it
in this formal way you're ready to
maintain it and so you go this route of
the formal distribution through cran
which is very convenient for the user
and not always for the developer
although often it is
oh sorry I hadn't been looking left oh
yes I didn't actually mention that so it
does exactly what it says does usually
these these function names are pretty
straightforward yeah here so I didn't
run it here because it actually takes a
little bit more setup then I'm just just
like a you have to add oxygen to it
before you can use it because that's how
it exports it but yes this is how if you
like them agree to package the deep
layer pipe whatever you like to call it
there is a way and use this to make it
very easy to export which is use pipe
and that will make it such that when you
load your package it will just be
available to you you don't have to load
deep pie or Magritte or anything like
that
and then you can also use it in your
code inside of your package very easily
there's a function called use get and
use github and use this that makes that
process easier you can install locally
on your machine with install there's
also a keyboard shortcut for this in our
studio you can also wrap this up as a
zip file and shipped off to somebody and
they can install it that way there's
lots of different ways and actually if
you're interested in you know some
people have internal packages that have
proprietary functions and data in it I
can't share it with other people so they
have to do it very carefully within
their own systems and so we have some
material on that on our workshop on my
organization's for a start package so if
that's something that is required for
your work where you need to be very
careful about what you're sharing you
may want to look into that as well all
right sometimes it I'll tell you the
truncated version of this story so
there's another story that I thought of
when I kind of made this connection in
my mind that's that's connected to
Buddhism and briefly the story goes that
there is a child who runs away from home
and is gone for many many years and
grows into adulthood and in this time
period
his father becomes very wealthy and
moves somewhere else and is in it like
an unrecognizable level of wealth in a
new place many many years down the line
this person encounters his father and
doesn't recognize them because he hasn't
seen him since childhood
the father recognizes him right away and
he tries to give all of this to him this
is yours this house this all this wealth
that I have built up this is your
inheritance and he runs away because
he's like what the hell is wrong with
this guy he's crazy he's trying to give
me all of this stuff I don't understand
it so the father instead has some of his
people go after him and hire him to
start you know like shoveling manure in
the in the stocks and you know just kind
of working his way up at a reasonable
way and so he slowly throughout time the
son works his way up through the
structure of the household to the point
we ends up managing the household and in
some versions of this
the father at this point tells him you
are my son that's why I wanted to give
this to you this is all yours and he's
totally shocked in another story at
version of the story that I like more um
at this point in the story the son has
actually already realized that all of
this is is his family and his
inheritance and so it's no shock to him
at all so to me this is what what coming
home to our packages is like is that as
in our user you have this inheritance of
this package infrastructure all of these
tools that make your life easier you
have these tools that make it so easy to
start start developing our packages and
they're yours for the taking there are a
few other helper points for this a few
helper functions and guides that I
really like so one is our markdown
driven development this blog post is
great her talk is great go check it out
she's also got a recent edition called
it's I think she called it a technical
appendix appendix that gives you all of
the guidance that you need to actually
structure your code in this way another
package that I really like is called are
our tools as in reproducible research
it's oriented towards academic research
but it's not it's not just suited for
that it works well for other things as
well and if you've heard of the idea of
a research compendium which is an idea
and reproducible research this package
tries to enact that so this will help
you create our packages for analyses in
a very opinionated manner that is very
very interesting so it's got a lot of
use this style functions to help you do
that there's also has anybody who's the
Golum package this is a relatively new
package that's really really neat so
there's also this stream of thought
going on now that shiny apps should be
archived ages as well and so Gollum is
an opinionated infrastructure for taking
a shiny app potentially a very large
shiny app and turning it into an r
package such that you can run a shiny
app through this structure
at the production level and then I
mentioned Drake already Drake is great
this is a workflow package and the link
here if you go to my slides this takes
you to how do you use Drake in the
context of I'm putting my functions
which Drake wants you to do into in our
package and so there's a way of thinking
about this and there's those terms as
well so my final request is that you
take an invitation to create some sort
of package alright a personal our
package is a great place to start all
right maybe you have a a ggplot you know
concoction that you use all the time and
you find yourself copying and pasting
that code over and over again that's a
great thing to put into a personal
package maybe you've got an R markdown
template that you can't remember the
ammo for and so you keep copying and
pasting it and that is a great thing for
a package to because you know that we
have this structure of creating our
markdown templates and packages and
views this makes that pretty easy as
well
using it in your work as an internal
package is really great it can be a
really great way to standardize work on
your team sharing functions of easily
creating an environment that is
installing the same packages very easily
and finally just taking an existing
project and adding a description file to
it telling it your dependencies and
using some of these tools whether it's
writing tests or loading functions to
this package mechanism that kind of
thing so I really invite you to try this
because I think that this our packages
should be you know right there with with
your data management tools your data
visualization tools you need workflow
tools as well and our packages are great
for it they're very well built for it
and so I think our packages should be a
part of our everyday toolkit and I
really invite you to try it out which
may feel a little daunting
this is by trimco room to say whose it
was a Tibetan teacher who says bad news
is that you're falling okay you falling
through the air you don't have a
parachute but the good news is there's
no ground trying out our packages all
right
Hadley's not gonna come to your house
cranes not gonna come to your house and
being like are you qualified to do this
okay
there's no ground so I really recommend
checking out the our packages book the
second edition
Jenny Bryan joined the team for it who
is like the best art communicator in the
world and it's amazing it's looking
really really good the first chapter has
a is called the whole game and it works
in our package from A to Z and it's
really nice it's a really nice Guide to
Getting like off the ground right away
using more or less all these tools that
I just I just showed so this first
chapter in particular but the whole book
is great for those details that of
course I couldn't go into and that's it
so thanks thanks for coming
I'm on Twitter if you're on Twitter find
me on Twitter
we're on Twitter right if you're not on
Twitter you got to get on Twitter no no
for our don't do other stuff on Twitter
no everything else on Twitter sucks
for our it's great I feel that I I feel
confident any cues or A's yeah well I
made with string I'm also string gun
femur string an extra and then these
type II things that was made with the
asking cast package which is um on the
are lib group I don't know if it's on
crane yet actually I think it is on
crane now which I heard about this
through Jenny Bryan's keynote at our
studio counts you use this and I thought
it was so cool I was like I gotta use
this immediately
it was pretty pleasurable to use I liked
it hang on well so I mean it's so I
pronounce it shirring on because what
could anybody provide the answer why I
pronounced it that way
yes Naruto yeah right so the name of
these slides is a reference to an anime
that I love and I pronounced it the same
in the oh yeah
strange
what's a shrink I pronounce in the anime
I don't know you a wasn't wasn't in the
anime though so maybe he pronounces
differently no it's not really that
important it's actually it it's
intentionally meant to be hard to
pronounce cuz he didn't want a lot of
people using it it's really nice is the
problem yeah he named it that because he
was sick of using Beamer slides because
they all looked the same and he thought
if he made a new package that everybody
liked then everybody would start using
it and impact the slides would all look
the same again so he made it hard to
pronounce so that people wouldn't talk
about it but they did anyway because
it's so good yes
yeah
ya know that and that's um that that is
I would say is a good practices
asserting that arguments you're saying
like you know you have an argument you
expect it that it's a character vector
or something like that
oh yeah that's a test yeah right right
right yeah cuz there's a little bit of a
subtle difference between validation
that you might be doing argument
checking at the front of the function
and then testing that you're doing to
make sure that it's getting the right
output yeah so so basically if you want
to be testing what it's returning that's
if you want to be examining what it's
returning that's a good thing for a test
and a good rule of thumb a good rule of
thumb when you're writing tests is and
this is a very soft guideline I often
don't do this but it's very good it gets
me going on is that for every our file
that you have also have a corresponding
test file and use this actually encodes
that because if you just type if you
have an R file open in an hour package
or something with the description file
and you type use R into the console it
will at arystar use test into the
council with no arguments it will create
a test with the same name as the file
that you have open and then open that
for you which is a really convenient way
and so I I have found myself doing it
more often because it encourages me to
do it because it's so easy should the
tests be functions
Yeah right right so if you're checking
inputs that's something that you might
want to put in the package or in the
function I would say generally you want
to be kicking the tires for the user
experience you know you want to make
sure that if it's a post error it is if
it's not supposed to error it's not
maybe you do want to make sure that that
validators checking so you would test
okay I this should produce an error that
I give it something that is supposed to
be a character vector and I give it
something else that should throw an
error and so you know again there's no
real strong hard rule of thumb for this
but you want to test things that are not
pretty much guarantees you know some
things it's like you just don't have any
doubt that they're gonna work and you
should not test too many internal things
because then if you change those
internal things it becomes a pain
because you have to update all your
tests so focus on the user experience of
the testing try and have a test file for
every far our function and you know some
people say that you should shoot for
there's a there's a function in dev
tools called
test coverage that will give you a
report how many lines of code that
you're testing and so you know over all
of them that you see a lot is 80% of
your code should be tested although that
itself is pretty soft guidelines
sometimes sometimes you need to do more
yeah this is um so it's it's that the
line actually gets executed sometime
during your testing yeah so every so it
actually calculates every line of code
in your AR folder and it's it checks
does this line of code actually get
fired off during this testing moment
here and I have found times where I'm
just like oh there's a whole part of my
function that it's not just not being
tested it actually is never ever gonna
run because it's impossible for this
logic to fire off and and run it so I
can just actually delete this code yeah
of course
yeah yeah you don't have to say anything
up this is the nice thing is that
they've set it up for you let's go back
here did you do this one right so what's
happening here is that I've written a
test and then I'm just running the test
function which is in dev tools and this
output is from dev tools so if you run
tests or command shift T or control
shift T depending on which operating
system you're on it will give you this
nice output you have to stipulate that
so Tesla has a formal structure of st.
of laying out expectations so if I run
this code I expect that it returns a
data frame that looks like this or
whatever and if it doesn't do that it
will error because it's actually running
our functions and will error and then
that's the failure so this is passing
because nothing's erroring yes you had
yours up for 100k
yeah
yeah and so test-driven development is
this idea that you should write actually
write the test before your code and then
write your code such that they pass the
tests which is interesting there's
actually that's a research done on it
that it seems like it's actually just
more important that you just write the
dang tests and if it encourages you to
do it it actually doesn't make your code
any safer but in some ways it does
encourage you to write tests because
it's it's like a front and foremost in
this yeah right right yeah yeah
absolutely and that's people who
subscribe to this really like it for
that reason
yeah it translates perfectly fine yeah
there's a question back here I think
yes yeah I have to be I have to hold my
tongue a little here yes yes so right so
it's it's a little of that and a little
bit that there is our certain
requirements and use this and and dev
tools are meant to try and get you most
of the way for most the most important
requirements so there are taking care of
those details for you there is there is
a document called writing our extensions
that has all this listed out it's very I
find it very difficult to find what I
need out of it but that is available and
every once in a while it's it's it does
you well usually the best bet is running
our command check which I didn't really
talk about here but our command check is
sort of this golden standard for is your
package in good shape running it a lot
often in many different places you know
running it on continuous integration
[Music]
services like Travis and a pair and
github actions there's a service Hawk
called our hub that will run it on a
bunch of stuff including the machines
that crane has or it tries to get as
close as possible and you just try and
get a clean bill of health every time
and that really helps I have never
submitted a package to Crane
successfully on the first attempt and
Hadley talks about in his book that you
know he's had packages rejected plenty
of times and you know it stings but he
just kind of you know he makes the
changes any any you know tries tries it
again and some reviewers are stiffer
than others in in those regards some are
extremely helpful I would say most of
the people in the front line are very
very helpful with it and the in the new
book the new our packages book
throughout the book they have a section
called crane notes or something like
that they give you a lot of details on
how each section is related to when you
actually go and submit it to cram so
you've actually submitted to Crane and
you've just had some you've had a lot of
like back and forth through triangle
yeah that's normal that's normal
most of the time it's helpful what's the
time it's it's good improvements yeah
and you should just make the changes in
resubmit yeah other questions yeah give
me the tweet version 280 characters I'm
going to count
[Laughter]
so if you would look at issue number
nine can your friends submit this
question to me interesting yeah well it
is I'm just joking by the way but it is
a it's I would like to see it I do think
that there's something wonky going on
with Prime with project activate it does
some weird things sometimes
yeah yeah because at the top level you
at the top level you don't need an
absolute path but it passes around on
the inside as one so when I say top
level I mean using the functions because
you're usually you're not using project
activate directly use this yeah you can
because it's an exported function and so
and there are certainly cases where you
would but and actually use this has kind
of its own way of dealing with things
anyway and so doesn't technically have
to be in our studio project but if
there's if there's something going on
around wrong on the inside with that it
sounds like you found a big bug to fix
yeah
but they want to reap recs
yes I think part of the reason I was
having fun running the test is some is
used this used in the test suite so that
like when I'm modifying if you if
project if it doesn't work on my system
that I'm well Minh it's not dentals is
not calling that function to run the
test suite but use this does use it to
set up test functions yeah it's not call
I don't believe that it's calling that
function at all okay or any use this
function I don't think because if that
was actually one of the points of
developing use this was to kind of make
this separation between project and
package setup which is a lot of what use
this is doing and then the build tools
the dev tools it's taken care of that's
actually building BR package that was a
Twitter thread but that's okay that's
okay
other question yeah
to me and Jana yeah yeah I agree yeah I
agree and most most things are very
reasonable that you get most things you
don't actually need to do because your
package can already do it they just
didn't find it and what's that
yeah right right but then everyone said
well you get an unreasonable yeah so I
right yeah so there's a whole system
yeah right so that's actually something
as a maintainer you are supposed to do
is if you're updating your package and
other packages depend on your package
there's a system of checking those what
are called reverse dependencies people
that depend on your package so there's a
there's a package called red dev tech
that will process all those for you
against your new version and make sure
that nothing's failing and I have had
this happen to me several times because
I have I have a DG plot-based package
that I do some weird stuff in and every
once in a while the new ggplot will
break it and so I have to fix those
things before it comes out but the good
news is that you know usually if if
people are non-responsive as a developer
non-responsive they'll usually you can
just say to crayon well you know I
emailed them this I gave them so you
know such and such amount of time to fix
it I never heard
and the do